Two thousand and 17 is the year that
Canada celebrates 150 years of
existence.
The specific day of their birth date was
the first of July.
So.
Well happy belated birthday
Canada.
Well did you at 150 years of existence
is not the only matter.
We should be congratulating Canada on
the country reached its One hundred and
50th anniversary in great shape because.
Well if there's something we can say
about Canada right now,
it's the country certainly in low.
Okay.
And yes.
Canada is also the homelands of many
celebrities that we all know.
Well,
Mazda has been one celebrity who has
been putting the international political
spotlight.
We're of course talking about Justin.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Not that.
Justin.
We met this one.
Of course,
Justin Trudeau.
It has reached its 150th birthday as one
of the richest countries in the world
with a top notch quality of life as well
as being one of the most admired
countries on earth.
Certainly not bad.
Right?
So now you might be wondering what is
the cause of all of this?
What are the main achievements that
Canada is celebrating after 150 years,
and importantly,
why is there a dark side to Canada?
We're going to answer all of these
questions in this video,
but first,
let us get some perspective,
a great transformation,
not have had much about Canada recently,
but we can certainly say that they all
know ordinary country.
In fact,
Canada is the second biggest country in
the wells with its territory covering
it.
Six different time zones and guess which
country has the most coastline in the
world?
Well,
no prizes,
if you guessed Canada,
of course as well.
Regular visual politic view is already
known either the size of the country,
surface and or its coastline determines
its wealth or how many opportunities
it's citizens have.
So then what's really behind the success
on Canada?
Well,
one key factor here is the disastrous
years the Canada had in the late
eighties and early nineties,
Canada suffered economic stagnation and
several crises.
These were bad enough that in 1995,
the Wall Street Journal called Canada,
an honorary member of the third world
due to its inability to control
government accounts.
Things then as you can see,
things have changed enormously.
Canada really knew how to play to their
strengths and get rid of their
weaknesses and especially the above.
All Canadians have really understood the
importance and the meaning of these two
words,
competitiveness and integration.
After those disastrous years of the
eighties and nineties,
Canadians realize that before thinking
about spending,
it is absolutely essential to think
about creating and they realized that in
order to do that,
they needed investment businesses and
trade a great deal of trade
well,
so as it was said,
so it was done in Canada is today these
seven freest economy in the world,
but if we're talking about freedom,
then we can't just talk about the
economic side of things.
The Fraser Institute publishes every
year,
something called the Human Freedom
Index.
This measures both the economic and the
civil freedoms that people enjoy.
Quite simply,
it measures what we can't do and what we
can't so well according to their
research.
Canada is the freest country on earth.
To give you a better idea of how this
compares to some other countries.
Well,
the USA,
they ranked 23rd.
Isn't,
isn't it 28th and Japan is flagging and
position 32.
Maybe the reason for this is these
strong decentralization that the country
has Canada instantly that into 10
provinces and three territories that
have so many unique regulations that in
2017 they actually had to sign a free
trade agreement among them.
You interprovincial trade deal expected
to add billions to the economy.
I think decentralization is absolutely
enormous and it is traditionally
resulted in higher costs for those
companies that don't operate in a single
region,
but in several different regions with
each region having different
regulations.
In Ontario,
petrol must be at least five percent
ethanol.
Manitoba insists on an eight point five
percent blend.
The positive side of this is that this
has worked as a counterweight to the
federal governments and it's encouraged
them to make pro citizen policies,
and that's something that has driven
good public policies anyway.
This new agreement has been created in
order to beat all these surprising
obstacles further,
as we talked about in a previous video.
There's also the Canadian bets on
multiculturalism and well,
let us be relative frank here.
Nowadays,
this country is one of the best examples
of integration in the entire world,
but ah,
the Canadian mosaic,
but also this Canadian multiculturalism.
And what's it all really about?
Well,
basically it consists of accepting that
cultural diversity is not a threat,
but it's an asset and a source of
opportunities for a country.
Now,
of course,
this multiculturalism is always
subordinate to a core set of values such
as democracy,
such as the rule of law and equality for
all people.
Yup.
Nope.
This needs that in order to be Canadian
and be welcomed into their country,
you don't have to replace your culture
with any other like the Canadian
culture.
You just have to accept and commit to
those core Canadian values.
I mean,
Canada has one of the largest
populations of immigrants in the world.
One out of every five Canadians weren't
born in Canada.
I mean,
for some cities like Toronto,
this figure it grows up to 50 percent or
even higher and it seems that it will be
even higher in the future because every
year more than 300,000 new immigrants
come to this country,
which is one of the highest immigration
rates in the entire world.
And you know,
the result of all of this is,
do you think is the problem?
Well,
it's.
It's actually no problem at all.
Yeah.
Look,
as we said in that previous video
integration in Canada,
it's certainly not for free.
There's the system that exists that's
based on three fundamental pillars,
points,
family reunification and refugees.
The most important one of these is the
points based system.
This exists do grants people,
residents or work permits.
It considers things like having a job
offer,
which is the most important thing,
or also maybe having a degree or having
the ability to speak
English and
I know the results of these policies.
Well,
almost 80 percent of Canadians think
that immigration is good for the
economy.
This is something that really shouldn't
be so strange when you consider that all
the statistics show that immigrants,
the brands,
new Canadians are more educated,
they work more hours,
they create more businesses as they draw
less dollars from social programs.
Now the question might be,
does Canada have,
does it have any rules about
immigration?
Certainly it does,
but this sort of welcoming culture
focused on integration.
Well,
it's pretty Rad.
Exactly.
Nineteen,
77.
Every Canadian citizen can hold any
other nationality without restriction,
so when someone immigrates to Canada
arounds after some years they can obtain
the Canadian passport.
They don't have to renounce their
previous nationality,
but if something might perfectly show
Canada spirits,
well that would be Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau.
Hi everyone.
I'm Justin Trudeau.
Yes.
Didn't Trudeau a political star?
Didn't he die?
He took office in 2015 almost buying
surprise and that just 44 years vein
today.
He is one of the most popular
politicians in the world and that's true
in Canada as well.
This is something that the Poles
clearly show a recent survey by abacus
data on the leadership of the prime
minister shows that 70 percent of
Canadians are confident that Trudeau
will successfully manage Canada's
relations with its allies.
Sixty three percent trust his
responsibility to make decisions,
and 62 percent believed that his
decisions will be good ones.
I mean,
how many politicians around the world
would really like approval?
Rating is like those.
We need a leader.
However,
Trudeau,
he's not a typical
politician,
not at all.
The Prime Minister of Canada has
personal,
a table,
a program,
and the form of government that's really
quite different from what's typically
being used and when you look at his
cabinet,
I mean it's a realistic sample of
Canada's reality.
Hey,
cabinet looks like Canada.
10 of the 30 ministers are women.
There's even an Afghanistan veteran and
an individual who is formerly a
volunteer in Niger.
There also business executives and even
some ministers who are Sikhs,
which is a religion native to the Punjab
state in.
Yeah.
The latest addition to that,
and they by the way,
has been who sent a Somali,
who arrived to Canada as a refugee at 16
years old and is now the minister of
integration.
Pretty amazing.
Alright,
today's political priorities.
Well there is international as these
cabinets.
One of the government of Canada is key
challenges is to boost trade among
nations.
Now pay attention to that foreign
affairs,
right?
Trade barriers hurt the people.
They are intended to help the curb
growth,
stifle innovation and kill employment.
This is a lesson we should learn from
history.
This is why Trudeau wants to sign a free
trade agreements with China.
Secondly,
unlike other governments to do,
doesn't just reject protectionism,
but he wants to stimulate a productive
change with artificial intelligence and
automation.
I mean why you can do technology if
there's something we've seen as history
has progressed,
is that technology improves people's
lives and to create some more jobs.
Not seeing something like that is too
complicated to do,
but the reality is that there are not
many world leaders who defend this pro
technology position talking about jobs
going away.
It's not exactly a popular line.
The other great challenge and maybe the
key value of Trudeau's government is
that bets on boosting civil rights and
sending Canada into an international
example of how this should be done.
Take a look at the power of this
picture.
Trudeau has become the first prime
minister to lead an Lgbtq pride parade.
There's also the most recently released
program,
Canada's feminist international
assistance policy.
Yep.
You heard that right.
Trudeau's government didn't hesitate to
declare itself feminist and among other
things,
they have decided to do focus and most
of their international cooperation
budgets on pushing winans rights where
they are most needed,
no this,
it's just a symbol,
but sometimes symbols that pretty
important.
Other symbols and gestures are is
positioned towards Syrian refugees and
pay close attention to this speech.
In recent months,
Canadians have opened their hearts and
their arms to families fleeing the
ongoing conflict in Syria and from the
moment they arrived,
those 31,000 refugees were welcomed not
as burdens,
but as neighbors and friends.
As new Canadian
today state
40,000 Syrian refugees have arrived in
Canada.
Almost half of them,
thanks to the sponsorship of Canadian
citizens had committed to be responsible
and looking after their wellness.
This is a great example of solidarity.
I mean,
it's one thing being kind and generous
and.
Well,
it's quite another to be naive.
Bus consider this.
The Canadian government has announced
its intention to increase military
spending by more than 70 percent from
now until 20,
24 in order to create a more agile and
modern armed forces.
Yes.
Trains,
doors open to technology integration,
civil rights,
security,
all these things don't sound bad at all,
right?
Especially if you consider that this
government understands that before
starting to discuss spending,
you have to talk about wealth creation.
Well,
I mean that's how Canada has reached its
One hundred and 50th anniversary.
Everything.
Bloody Marvelous,
right?
Well,
wait a second.
I mean not exactly.
Yeah,
there are certainly some shadows,
but we're actually gonna have to leave
those for another video.
Something we're probably going to call
the dark side of Canada.
Don't think that it's all just rainbows
and butterflies in Canada.
Certainly not.
Not at all.
Well,
so do you not forget to subscribe to our
channel so you don't miss that video as
well that will allow you to hear the
other side of the story and now we'd
like to know your opinion or do you
think of true dope?
You can leave us your comments below and
also by clicking on the survey on the
screen now and do not forget to check
out our friends at the reconsider media
podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine,
and as always,
thank you for that.
The.